hello everyone and welcome back to day
two of the Magnus Invitational we are at
Game four of the match and Pony vs.
Fabiano Caruana like I said a game won
ended in a draw
even though Knepper was a little bit
better he really surprised well he
didn't surprise Fabi with the French if
I was a four of course expecting the
French but he really got up and got a
good position there then game two that
incredible opportunity for an F for that
nice h4 idea going for the bishop on g6
but too bad for him that he missed it
then game three another French that ends
in a draw but this one a lot more solid
I decided to skip that one as well and
now we are at game 4
so first three games ended in a draw
whoever wins this wins the match or it's
a draw and then we go into our mageddon
so let's see what happens here a nipple
again a liking game to opens with E for
and again if Robbie goes for a 5 we have
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to b5
again hurry Lopez is on the board we
have a 6 more fees defense Bishop a4
Knight f6 and castles but now instead of
the our tango squid Bishop it would be
found in the ship to c5 Fabi just goes
for Bishop to e7 a nice closed rule opus
as he didn't enjoy the position he got
against nepo in Game two of course who
would and he decides to mix it up a bit
that's ok d3 pineapple we have these six
and the castles oh sorry c3 and the
castles by black we have Nightbeat the d
tomb all very standard stuff rook to e8
and rook to e1 black goes the blush of
the faith to give control of the e5
square and d for now just challenging in
the center we have b5 pushing the bishop
back and just brush about at the b7 here
we have b3 by nipple and now comes a
move that has never been played before
there is a known g6 move and even d5 was
played here in one game a pentile
harikrishna defeated Alexander Morris a
witch with with d5 here but Fabi goes b4
and it is a new move so already as I've
moved 12 we have a completely new game
so let's see how Nippo deals with this
he goes Bishop to b2 and it makes sense
you if captures you just want to keep an
eye on the d4 square
we have a five by five we have a five by
Fabi and now comes d5 grabbing more
space in the center night to be 8 and
now night the c4 just an excellent
outpost for that night
we have CSEC safari challenges that
extended pawn on d5 and now d captures
in c6 we have Knight captures and a3
they are putting more pressure on the b4
pawn but Fabi just continues with Bishop
to e6 puts pressure on the knight and
the neighbors shifted over to e3 he
wants to bring it to eat - f5 or maybe
d5 in some lines if if needed so g6 are
taking away the f5 Square from Naples
night and now Queen to d2 developing the
Queen connecting rooks we have Queen to
b6 Fabi does the same and now comes h3
now taking away g4 from black and also
may be nice to g4 will be possible in
the future we look at the c8 and now
rook a to D 1 we have rook e to D 8 and
here here is basically the critical
position of the game because here Nippo
played a c4 when in fact first you want
to capture on b4 and only after captures
push c4 the problem with as you can see
now the be for square is occupied by the
black pawn the problem with nip was
immediate c4 is that he allows Fabi to
capture on a 3 and after captures he
gets the be for square for his Knight
and now it's a much different position
than than the one where where this point
occupies this Square and the night and
c6 doesn't really have anywhere to go
so here Bishop to be one nape of course
keeps the disrepair and now Bishop the
h6 by 5 shifts the bishop - this is a
beautiful diagonal
Quinta ytube getting out of the bishops
way and now Bishop back to b7
challenging the e4 pawn Knight to g4 now
the the bishop and the Queen defended
with capture son g4 h captures and now
Knight to a 6 this Knight is now coming
to c5 to add more pressure at the e4 but
also to be 3 so all of this comes from
nippers c4 move if he played capture
some before first before c4 then it's ok
but you know
such is the way of the reuleaux PES we
have looked at b3 now defending the pawn
button is still knife the c5 forcing
this trade with Bishop captures we have
rook captures on c5 and now Queen to d1
putting more pressure on these six and
now Bishop the c8 challenging the g4
pawn we have Knight the d2 getting the
knight out of the way so now the Queen
defends the pawn and are just Bishop to
e6 and here bishop the a2 adding another
defender to the pawn here we have Queen
to b4 now with with more pressure on the
night on d2 and then out comes f3 f3
does take care of the points here on e4
and d4 but you create a lot of dark
square weaknesses here and okay rook the
c6 now adding more defense that the d6
pawn so now the Queen can move you don't
want your Queen stuck here guarding the
d6 pawn and we have g3 now we have
worked a 8 preparing to bust open the
position with a 4 and King to g2 by
nipple we have a 4 and now comes Luke 2
e 2 the rook will be very useful here
guarding the second-ranked 8 capture son
b3 and the neppo captures with the best
robe Bishop captures and B 3 and now
rook to a3 and it just seems like all of
these resources that fob is throwing a
tempo all of them come from that early
c4 by nipple
we have night the b1 now attacking the
rook forcing it to move but looked a 1
which is an even better Square for the
rook since now you cannot move the
knight and now it's it's really it's
really tough deciding what to do here
nipple went to work the b2 defending the
knight and the bishop once again but now
he runs into Bishop captures on c4 so
it's it's a very complicated position
you can't you can't of course capture
here because the Rope hangs and well
there's just the threat of capturing the
rook so it's hard to decide what to do
here Knepper plays the absolute best
move here he plays Queen to c2 move and
now it's not as as clear what you want
to do here for example if you capture
the rook you run into Queen captures on
c6 and now you cannot capture the night
here and win material because of Queenie
8-track King g---seven Queen captures
with Trek and now you deliver mate
so this is nepos idea so instead if a
bee goes King to g7 now the same line
will no longer work because after Queen
captures and Queen eiated this will not
be checked so it doesn't work but now we
have Bishop captures in c4 and the now
comes rook captures on c4 Fabi once the
once the trade Queens here Napo declines
he's not interested Queen to f2 and now
comes Queen to a5 of course he gets his
queen out of the way as well we have
night study - getting getting the night
into the game and now rooks eat the c1
and now you can put a lot of pressure
here towards the black King we have nice
to be three here with the monster fork
but it still runs into rook to g1 and
this is exactly what Fabi plays I might
even use this as a thumbnail looking
pretty good and yeah here
rook the g1 chick and you have to give
up the Queen for two rooks you even if
you move away black can still force the
trade with rook to g1 and now there are
no moves you have to capture and we get
the same idea
so after rook g1 we have Queen captures
rook captures with check King captures
and now Queen the II one with check King
h2 guarding the pawn here and now Queen
to f1 putting pressure on the rook end
on the f3 pawn so rooks III still
keeping an eye on the pawn and now
Bishop to g5 Fabi makes room for the h1
so now it's Queen and Bishop against two
rooks in the night with Fabi being up
upon so black is better but it's it's by
no means a walk in the park
so rook to g2 and nipples the nipples
the plan here is to create some sort of
a fortress where the Queen and Bishop
will be unable to do anything
and of course so hopefully you will not
help the black create any passed pawns
so Queen to e one pressuring the rook
and now rook to d3 we have Queen the b1
attacking both the knight and the rook
and rook just wrote back to c3 net
forces you're the one who has to find a
plan here we have h5 by Fabi and now
we've G captures each characters and now
Knight back to d2 attack
the Queen Queen 31 once again and now
here Nippo doesn't like night the c4 and
instead he goes rook the d3 the problem
however is that now your knight is stuck
you cannot move it because your rook
Hanks and Fabi just shows that the d6
pawn is off-limits you just place King
to f8 and now the problem with capturing
this at this point here is that it runs
into h4 and h4 just wins problem is you
cannot capture it if you capture this
runs into Bishop f4 check and you're
just lost here king h3 Queen delivers
check you're gonna go here and I'll just
captures and after King moves you can
just play King g7 not allow the King to
escape and now Queen to h3 will be made
whatever white plays so instead after
this h4 you of course will not be able
to capture but whatever you play you
still lose for example 94 you open up a
discovery on the Queen still each
capture assign g3 with check King
captures Queen e2 check
look the g2 and now again Bishop to f4
check we run into the same idea Queen
captures on f3 check King gauge for
Queen captures and g2 and you are now
getting checkmated so after King to f8
nepo sees that the the pawn is
off-limits he goes looked at f2 instead
and now comes h4 fabric continues of
course he wants to open this up to be
able to play Bishop to f4 check but now
it's not as strong because now the rook
moves so the King has GT squared this
row just runs into King to g2 and you
don't have a good way of continuing the
attack so far we just grabs the pawn and
here we have looked back to g2 we have
King to e7 getting the King out of
harm's way even though there was a
better movie in the position but we're
gonna get back to that rook the b3 by
nipple and now Queen to II 1 and now
nipple goes for Knight to c4 and now
there's a problem because there is a
move that wins the game for black and
feel free to pause the video and try to
spot this move while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and going back to the
exact same idea that we've already shown
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show it's Bishop to g5 that's
the move I mentioned the previous a few
more moves ago that was possible here if
Abby finds it and now it's a problem you
are again threatening Bishop check here
and the rook is now in g2 so that's a
huge problem and it's it's not easier to
do anything about it because well look
f2 is impossible since the Queen blocks
it and if you try rook G 1 then again
Bishop f4 check King 2 H 1 and now just
Queen 2 F 2 threatening mate and there
is not much you can do here rogue g2
Queen f1 check here and Queen h3 will be
checkmate so after Bishop g5 neppo did
the only thing he could he captured the
bishop even though it runs into Queen to
h4 check King to g2 and now just Queen
captures and g5 way to check King f2 and
now Queen to c1 so all of a sudden its
Queen against a rock and the night which
is much better than a queen and a bishop
against the night and two rooks so
tonight's the e3 nip of course will
still try to create some sort of a
fortress but Queen to d2 check King g3
and now came to East 6 we have Knight
the f5 and here another great trick by
Napo he's trying to get Bobby to go for
d5 which seems like a reasonable idea
because if you capture you lose the
night and if you do nothing then black
gets a passed pawn
however rook b6 check forces the king to
d7 and now just wrote a check and you
pick up the pawn so it would be it would
be bad and here it will be most likely a
draw this does seem like a reasonable
castle a reasonable fortress so after
night at 5 Bobby just continues Queen d1
harasses the rook rook the b2 in the now
Queen the g1 with Czech rug g2 nipa
blocks Queen e1 check King to g4 and now
Queen the c1 going for Queen to f4 check
so night the g7 with Czech we've came to
have sex going after the night King
Knight to the h5 check King to g6 and
now f4 blocking the Queen's
root root 2 g 5 but now King 2 H 6
giving white the move and there aren't
all that many moves you can play the
knight cannot move as Queen captures and
therefore comes if you move the King
away from the defense of the night you
lose the night and there simply aren't
aren't any reasonable moves here you
could try something like rook to H 2 to
maybe go for some discoveries but then
Queen the G 1 check is a huge problem
you have to defend and then you lose the
night sorry then I denied and so our
King the f5 was played trying to trick
Bob into capturing the night and run
into root 2 H to checkmate but Bobby had
a different idea instead of running into
checkmate
Bobby decided to deliver checkmate so
you all see it it's mating - without
even pausing the video Queen to c8 check
and we we could see this one in slow
motion there it is
Queen to see a trick we have King to f6
only move and now of course Quinta
eastex
is checkmate so really really a wild
game and really ashamed for nipple for
losing this match because he was clearly
better in Game one which I still might
show tomorrow I will consider it it was
a good French defense and completely
winning in Game two but of course you
have to find it that's nice stage for a
night to h4 idea and then he just loses
the game for and with it the match so
yeah excellent game by Fabi I I do hope
you enjoyed it and regarding the the
gearing mvl match like I said the first
two games were won by MBL and the two
other games were drawn so I doubt I will
be showing those as they weren't all
that all that interesting but yeah and
we all won that match and here I just so
I don't forget here are the standings
from chess 24 website there's the cross
table here you can see that Maxine washi
holographic being river and info beyond
karana i leading with three points and
magnus carlsen
is fourth with two points as he didn't
win straight up in the match he had to
go to armageddon so you receive less
points and Hikaru he also got 1 point
for reaching Armageddon and then future
Nippon Ichi and Aguirre is
points even though you know yeah the
point you don't reflect the quality of
their moves because though they played
some really really awesome games but
yeah those are the standings after round
1 day 2 and so I do hope you enjoyed
that as well I would like to thank
Castle Prendergast for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot that
really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous video Sarah thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational so thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your Sunday